[Musique]
rudy duville bonjour oui bonjour bonjour
les auditeurs de la martinique la
première alors vous êtes candidat sur la
4e circonscription celle du sud vous
êtes membre de la martinique ensemble
est aussi tête de file de l'opposition
diamant et votre suppliante c'est yvonne
fritz du marin qu'est ce qui motive
aujourd'hui votre candidature donc
aujourd'hui j'encourage à chaque
martiniquaise et martiniquais de
s'engager quel que soit dans le monde
associatif le monde cultuelle sportive
on a besoin que chacun
à la place qu'il occupe de faire de
dégager un sourire pour la martinique
donc moi je mon engagement et leur
politique donc j'ai commencé en 2008 au
diamant en qualité de conseiller
municipal
ensuite sixième adjoint premier adjoint
et aujourd'hui je suis chef de file de
l'opposition donc je continue mon
engagement sous les législatives avec
yvonne crise on a tous les deux le même
parcours et c'est un tandem qui
complémentaire donc c'est une offre
politique très intéressante pour le sud
une autre couleur politique pour le sud
donc c'est une alternative crédible
aujourd'hui donc quand vous dites une
autre couleur politique pour le sud dans
quel état d'esprit vous situer face à au
duel annoncé miller mal jeunes donc
aujourd'hui la martinique ensemble c'est
un jeune parti jeune parti nous nous
sommes présentés aux élections de la 7e
donc sous 14 listes présentes nous
sommes arrivés troisièmes donc nous
considérons aujourd'hui avec la
confiance des martiniquaises et des
martiniquais que la martinique en somme
est la troisième force politique d'où
cette nouvelle couleur politique
proposée aux électeurs donc aujourd'hui
on ne sera pas les arbitres de ce match
entre
ce qui est annoncé nous notre notre
autre point commun c'est de s'intéresser
aux électeurs de retrouver leur
confiance et de leur proposer une
alternative que des concernant la
circonscription dans laquelle vous vous
présentez quelles seront selon vous les
deux trois priorités
en tant que député donc le député qu'il
soit dans la circonscription sur nos
centres bon ce sont pratiquement la
problématique des martiniquaises et des
martiniquais donc nous voyons bien et à
travers du vote à la présidentielle
il ya deux messages il ya un premier
message qui est une alerte fondamental
pour les élus les élus en place et pour
ceux qui viennent aussi donc c'est à
dire retrouver la confiance avec les
électeurs parce que eux aussi ils ont
besoin de participer jeudi à la
construction de la matinée qu'ils ont
besoin de transparence politique
ils ont besoin d'exemplarité en
politique donc la loutre offre
aujourd'hui
caractérise je dis oui cette attente de
la population est là l'autre partie ce
sont les problématiques que nous avons
sur le territoire tels que le le pouvoir
d'achat la problématique de la jeunesse
la sargasse donc ce sont des
problématiques qui sont récurrentes et
qui reviennent à chaque fois et moi je
dis si problématique ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui puisque en 2009 j'étais
aussi dans la rue à manifester contre la
vie chère aujourd'hui la sémantique a
changé ça s'appelle le pouvoir d'achat
donc à voir on wire nouveaux soucis des
pratiques qui existent forcément
contribué à trouver des solutions
adaptées à la matinée pouvoir d'achat il
faut toucher à l'octroi de mer pouvoir
d'achat c'est un vaste c'est un vaste
chantier vaste chantier moi je dis
aujourd'hui une urgence sociale qu'il
faut répondre rapidement par soit par
des gels
de taxation ou des suppressions de
taxation qui peut être fait au niveau
local lorsqu'on regarde le prix du
gasoil qui a eu 81 le sans plomb et
aucun héroïsme cote donc faut six mois
pourquoi pas mettre le transport gratuit
le temps qu'on légifère jeudi sur toute
la matinée que j'entends bien qu'on
légifère souhaite une loi donc là c'est
une réponse rapide par rapport à martine
et l'autre l'autre point qui est la
question de légiférer il faut tout
remettre à plat le système de prix
amandine et nous aujourd'hui l'octroi de
mer son idée premier c'était de protéger
la production locale artisanale il faut
qu'on garde l'octobre l'octroi de mer
cependant il faut qu'on va voir la
philosophie sa 10e concours
rafraîchissent l'octroi de mai entre le
moment il a été fait et on nous sommes
en 2022 on voit bien qu'il ya quand même
des petites aberrations des petites ou
des grandes puisque ça contribue au
portefeuille de martinique c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui demandé aux martiniquais
de financer le fonctionnement des
communes nous nous disons non parce que
c'est à l'état de le faire parce que
cette taxe n'existe pas en france
hexagonale elle est remplacée par la
dotation globale de fonctionnement donc
ce sont des points que nous devrions
voir une fois en
responsabilité avec l'état et aussi
travailler en concertation avec les
autres élus les présidents président de
la 7ème et le président de l'exécutif et
de l'assemblée les autres parlementaires
et les présidents de l'est de ce pays de
façon à parler d'une même voix d'une
même voix sur cette problématique de
toile au maire en 10 secondes qu'avez
vous à dire aux électeurs en 10 secondes
je dis aux électeurs de nous faire
confiance de faire confiance à la
martinique ensemble de faire confiance à
ce jeune diamantinoise rudy du ville qui
en 2008 et en politique au diamant donc
vous pouvez
je peux témoigner de mon exemplarité de
mons et 8 et de ma force de travail et
d'engagement voter aux idées du ville
yvonne fritz de façon à renouveler la
classe politique ou du ville je vous
remercie merci bien chers auditeurs la
matinée que la première
[Musique]